after Julian McMahon is known for
playing plastic surgeon dr. Troy on the
hit show dip-tuck it's a role that
earned him a Golden Globe nomination now
the Australian actor is tracking down
notorious bad guys in the new CBS drama
FBI most wanted in the scene you're
about to see his character Special Agent
Lacroix tries to reason with a mother
taking justice into her own hands after
her son is sentenced to 20 years in jail
who is Tyson is a special agent just
lacroix of the FBI I've been listening
to your conversation I'd like to work
with you trying to get justice for
Kendall yes Tyson what he uses no
justice but right now I'm concerned
about you and I'm concerned about
Rebecca don't worry about me get the
judge to give his word that he'll change
the sentence I'll give you my word I'll
try but I'd like to ask you to do
something for me
I'd like you to think about turning
yourself in to me McMann joins us now I
gotta tell you Julian good morning
also morning my kind of show that's
delicious I love that clip I like I like
the idea of the FBI not bringing justice
to the Most Wanted but bringing the most
wanted it is a lot of fun before we get
onto that you you've taught me something
this morning and that is that I am a
chord hoarder a program for us I'm gonna
go home and throw them all away I'll
take him into Best Buy whatever it is
your character Jenny wait sorry yes back
to best water boy he's not a court order
he's too busy he's an interesting time
in his life his wife has passed away
tell us about him yeah look he's a
fascinating individual is a great
character to play he's he's kind of a
bit of a genius in the FBI world he has
this ability to kind of calculate
circumstances and situations and people
and see crime scenes and put things
together see things doing that other
people don't
yes absolutely absolutely and then as
you said he has this kind of
relationship with his daughter when we
come into the show we find him at a
point where he lost his wife two years
ago yeah
in Afghanistan yeah and so he's raising
his daughter on his own so he's
struggling between kind of being the
father and the mother at the same time
he's getting some hair but some help
from the grandparents but he's really
kind of trying to find that balance of
how do you raise an 11-year old girl and
how do you go to work and do what you
need to do I think there's part of his
system that needs to do what he's doing
can't kind of survive without it the
heels yeah I understand onset there are
real investigators there to kind of
guide you guys toward accuracy realism
absolutely well first of all we started
when we started on the show we did a
whole bunch of stuff with FBI guys in
regards to tactical stuff and you know
approaching buildings and coming out of
cars and you know it could get quite
clunky at some point in time so it's
really good to get some kind of
direction in that area and then we have
somebody with us on set all the time and
that's a lady who's an ex-fbi agent
she's really talented and just really
helps us kind of make things real and
did she have a roll your eyes at you
guys and you guys like she rolls her
eyes all the time and I go and she says
she comes I would never do that and I
say does it look good at the top you
were Australian I must be very hard to
be working over here and watching what's
happening look it's devastating I have
family over there I have a lot of
friends over there it's what are you
hearing from them well obviously the
fires and everything that we hear in the
news but what I'm hearing is the issues
that are kind of becoming a part of the
environment that they have there and
that is issues with people's health
branchial issues problems with people's
eyes people literally haven't seen the
Sun for three to four weeks and you know
all of the debris and everything that's
going on as well as everything else
Australia was always a vulnerable place
because the ozone so this is reinstating
great to see you please come back
you